the Pentagon wasted $28 million buying
the wrong color camouflage to help
modernize Afghanistan's National Army
the Pentagon purchased uniforms with a
forest green camouflage pattern
handpicked by the Afghan defense
minister despite the fact that the
country is 98% desert the special
Inspector General for Afghanistan
reconstruction called it insane we
wasted 28 million of taxpayers money in
the name of fashion because the defense
minister thought that a pattern was
pretty what if the Minister of Defense
liked purple or liked pink they also
spent extra on tailoring like using
zippers instead of buttons jacking up
the price of uniforms with little to no
actual value yes this really happened